this might be an Irish trait or it just
might be a trait that we both share but
it is uh hanging on to old cars my
father would drive a car until it had
300,000 miles on it and the paint would
fall off and then he once hired a house
painter to repaint the car cuz it was
cheaper and this car looked like it had
cystic acne it was a bad you know
terrible and he just kept it going but
it was a point of Pride you keep a car
going my first car was a 1992 Ford
tourist
I still have it it's not worth anything
um but I still hang on to it because in
in my lineage you hang onto a car
forever you have a
67 Corvette corette Goodwood green 327
350 can flat shift it can move now do
they let you drive it not
anymore but no Ser I think I saw a tear
in your eye right there oh by the way
you know I they take me out to the
Secret Service test track which is an
old Runway yeah I've got my Corvette up
to 132 mph it's only 327 the reason I
had the Corvette 1967 when I was
marrying my deceased wife who came from
her dad was a Navy guy owned some
restaurant wonderful wonderful man but
they're of Greater means than we were
and I was he wanted to give us a wedding
gift and he couldn't afford anything of
consequence he said Joey give me your
car I had then I had a
62 Chevy Belair and she had a Pontiac
Tempest of 64 I guess it was I'm not
sure the year and he said I'll fix them
all up and that'll be my gift to you
guys you can come pick them up she was
down in Delaware 10 days before the
wedding before she went home so we went
to pick up the car at the dealership he
he was a manager of the dealership yeah
anyway we pull up and uh all everybody
from the mechanics to the sales person
everybody's outside and and waiting for
us and so we get out of the car walk up
and and dad said I'm going to give you
your wedding gift early guys and
everybody separated a brand new 67
Goodwood green Chevy Corvette and
hardtop and uh and he was so proud
because he couldn't afford it he could
afford the payments right and uh so I'm
talking with Jay Leno going out the
second time to race these cars and he
said you want to sell your car and I
said he's probably listening so I got
hope I get it right he's not listening
to this don't worry about it well he
made learn something yeah he should he
should learn but but anyway I I said you
know you have I noticed you have in a
glove box you have the original sticker
yeah I said yeah I didn't realize have
all that and he said uh you want to sell
it and I said I don't think so my son
would come down from heaven because they
rebuilt the engine all original parts
and he said uh you get
$144,000 for it and I said no can't do
it for 36 years I was listen to the
poorest guy in Congress but I couldn't
separated for that car but by the way
the new Corvette it's coming out
electric 0 to 60 2.9 seconds you going
to drive that one I'm going to give it a
shot I drove the other one I can
distract the Secret Service you can make
a run for the car by the way by the way
I drove one of those big Ford Broncos
yeah electric yeah 4.9 seconds oh it's
unbelievable mine is 5.2 right and
that's flat shifting but all kiding
aside it I mean this I just love love
car I don't know a damn thing about the
engines I don't know anything about it I
just know how to drive them and I love
it I just know there's a big wheel in
the front and I put on the gas and I
move forward and that's all I know by
the way you know the new ones they have
they have a launch switch like I I I got
the a portion yeah up to 171 mil hour
which you do is you put your foot on the
gas and the brake and on the button on
the on where the the gear shift is you
hit launch and you watch and there's a
launch symbol inside the speedometer and
it counts down and when it gets down to
zero you just take your foot off the
breake and you move it is
like it is incredible hearing you talk
about cars it's the most
excited oh
[Laughter]
yeah